I was recently speaking to a mother who
described herself when the subject of
her children's father came up as a mummy
on my own this struck me as a strange
form of words to use until I realized
she was doing everything she could to
avoid being labeled with the ultimate
stigma that of a single mother we have a
long history of blaming social problems
on women
now one NHS body has had to apologize
for refusing IVF to single women on the
basis they are a burden on society and
unable to bring out the best outcomes
for the child we all know the NHS has
limited resources I think it should
think again about how important it is to
support single people who want fertility
treatment after all these are children
who would be desperately wanted and
valued but if we really can't afford it
then put it down to a lack of money not
the single mothers who are frankly more
likely to deserve a medal than a slap in
the face like this firstly I think it's
important that we stop pressed because
we finally found a topic - I agree well
I never thought I would see the day and
I agree with Afra I completely agree
with you and before I get into the
reasons why let's just hear from Andrew
bland from the NHS southeast he says I
would like to apologize for any offence
and distressed caused by birth the
wording in the southeast London
treatment access policy in relation to
single woman's access to IVF treatment
and the review document it refers to we
agree this wording is not acceptable and
we will take action to address this as
we conduct a rapid review of the policy
in relation to access criteria for
funding IVF so that aside I completely
agree with you there is still a stigma
on single mums and it's absolutely
shocking now the NHS has got a very it's
got lots of challenges not least funding
challenges and whether or not the NHS
should be funding IVF is something
that's always a burn of contention I do
believe that you should be offering
people at least one round if that's what
they want to do to be a parent but this
whole I had an experience in whole and I
won't name the clinic but when I tried
to freeze my eggs because I wasn't a
situation to have children
I was denied and the opportunity to
freeze makes as a private paying patient
there's nothing to do the NHS and when I
asked them why would you not freeze my
eggs they told me that their policy was
not to do egg freezing for those that
have chosen it for lifestyle reasons I
was so enraged because they have viewed
my reasons for not having a child yet to
be a lifestyle choice as opposed to
anything else and that infuriated me
that was a private do you mean because
it wasn't to do with infertility but you
weren't ready yes so what they said is
for example if I unfortunate cancer and
I was going through some treatment and I
had to physically had to freeze eggs
because I had no choice they would do it
but because I was just wanting to do cuz
I didn't have a partner etc they were
unwilling to take my money to do that
and that is the state of people's
perceptions sometimes when it comes to
facility I think that single mums
especially solar mums by choice they
know what they're going into they've
made this decision they're going into
often with eyes open and to call them
burdens like this is a disgrace well she
this yes by the way I agree with what
you say I don't press there is a stigma
for single-parent mother's oh that's
awful but it's not a we've often said
the NHS is not a bottomless pit good
you're presented and you've got enough
funding to fund one woman with a one is
a wife and up with a husband and the
other a single woman you're gonna give
it to well what if you're only going to
be able to fund
who's gonna get it well I don't know I
don't know how you make that decision
but you said isn't it but your
decision-making criteria shouldn't be
based on their relationships - okay so
how what will determine your decision
which of those two women one as a
husband or a partner one is a single or
lone parent who's going to get the cash
well I don't know cuz I don't know how
they make a decision to make that
decision well probably flip a coin
because they're both equals it's a great
way to run medicine flipping a coin are
you suggesting that you should
prioritize what's good at the couple
well I think this this this what would
you this reflects the dilemma that it is
really difficult to do I don't I think
you should establish a set of objective
criteria which is very difficult to do
because I don't think that you can
decide whether someone's more deserving
of having a chance based on their
relationship status or where they live
which is currently actually what would
you think for most people it's a
postcode lot
you can't do that you can't put a dollar
map and then when I put it back to you
I'm sure this this is occurring all the
time because resources are so limited
but I just find it's a very difficult to
bake because we've read this week in the
papers are cancer clear up rates in this
country are abominable there are
problems with dying early diagnosis
we've got continuing problems with the
NHS we've got pressure for obese people
and smokers to be required to pay for
their treatment even though they've been
paying their taxes and yet we say we can
provide money to give single women IVF
because they think they're now ready to
have a child I'm sorry I think we've got
to make decisions based on the fact the
energies there is to cure illness and
disease not dissatisfaction I would I
think that is the debate really what is
the purpose of the NHS but I'd be very
careful about dismissing the quest of
people who want to have children and
need IVF to do it it's a heartbreaking
position for people to be in if they
can't have children and they want the
state to help them which but when the
state has got so much pressure on
resources and we've got people dying of
cancer who shouldn't be dying half of
people who get diagnosed with cancer
this cancers already spread
there's something going seriously wrong
with the NHS and we're spending money on
wrong priorities I would agree with that
but I think we need to be thinking about
how to develop a modern NHS that can
meet the realistic needs of people
across the board not just and of course
treating cancer should be an absolute
priority and other serious illness but I
don't think we should confine our
ambition to that I think that IVF is
something that we should be able to
offer in a fair way across the country
because at the moment some people can
get do things one it's important to
mention that the nice fertility
guidelines say that women under 40
should receive at least three full
cycles of IVF and right now while sixty
percent are getting one or a partial one
23 percent are getting two cycles and 13
percent are getting the full three so
there's that there's also the language
that you use the idea of single single
mothers being a burden on society back
and it's what you've said earlier the
idea of constant
we blaming the woman I mean most women
who find themselves as single mothers if
there was an available partner who could
help them raise that child who was
responsible they could rely on
they obviously choose that but to blame
the woman for the absence of someone to
help her is ridiculous but where are you
on Andrews point that and even a shell
that it's not a bottomless pit
and Andrew makes a fair point does he
not that if we're not able to look after
people who have cancer who've paid in
their taxes in some instances for
decades how is the funding to be
addressed for me how would you do but
please don't say well we just need to
find money because that's binary to say
we I think because we all agree I can't
say no to waiting five years for a hip
hop-eration
these are these not priorities I think
the current situation is that this NHS
body that we were talking about and I
know that they've apologized now it
didn't say the reason we're not funding
languages to they did something deeper
they didn't say we can't afford it which
I accept we do have limited resources
it's heartbreaking but a rational
conversation does need to take place
about what we can fund on the NHS but
they said that it's not desirable for
single women to have IVF because they
become a burden on society I think you
know I think that view does exist then I
think they've made the choice already
what niche Nick put to Michelle if
there's a married couple or a couple a
couple versus a single mother they're
gonna good I know you were a single dad
raising little did you you know this
stigma that exists towards single
mothers do you feel that there's
anything of that towards a single father
or is it a different a different
honestly I never experienced it I I
really didn't experience it and I was
actually gonna pick either you because
and I mean perhaps cause I was a little
bit in the world as a single dad but do
you think there is still then a single
mum stigma sorry sorry but no absolute
and they've apologized with but more
broadly do you still think societies
almost like I don't know the 70s all
those sixties you still think it's not I
mean
debate we have quite frequently as about
knife crime right
the serious problem knife crime not how
many times do we hear politicians saying
it's because of single moms it's because
the black boys being raised by single
moms as if as if the women doing a
difficult job of raising children on
their own are somehow the cause of
social breakdown I think that narrative
still exam not accusing you of it like I
think it exists in society and I feed
that I see this NHS statement has one
symptom and even this mother that I
mentioned in my intro you know people
are devising all kinds of language to
get out of any any prospect of people
labeling them single mums I think it
reflects a deeper attitude towards them
well my advice to someone if they're
feeling stigmatized about being a single
parent is earn it and just get on with
it because you rock the work that
they're doing on there and so good angry